facing lefty tyler anderson the era at
467 i don't think
tells the whole story i think he's uh
pitched quite a bit better than that
this year
got him looking yes again that's shaking
his head
hit the target almost one hands this out
into left and
i don't think kai tom moved an inch
and now facing a guy that has had a lot
of success against him and justin turner
that is a high fly ball deep center
field
reynolds out of room it's gone home run
justin turner
continues to master tyler anderson his
second home run against him his tenth of
the year
and that ball was right at the heart of
the plate
and justin turner does not miss it puts
a great swing
27 year old tony gonzalen who makes his
season debut
after missing the first couple of months
with a sore shoulder
what has to feel like in eternity since
his last time in a big league mound
godzilla's 2-2 got him with the splinter
for his first strikeout
brian reynolds switch-hitting center
fielder he homered in the ninth last
night
and he swings at the first ball here
bounces it to albert pujols he throws to
second
lucks the return thrower first too late
and reynolds beats it out keeps the
inning alive but they do get the force
in the middle
to aboard for polanco
line off the glove of pull holes runner
waved home
the throw to the plate he is going to be
safe
what a slide if it holds up for reynolds
right to that edge feet first and snuck
in there two walks in the inning that
loads them up
for michael perez who homer is a pinch
hitter yesterday
here it comes he struck him out getting
a fast ball by him to somehow
limit the damage to one
chase is up that's where he wanted to
put it nailed it
here's the one two now swinging a line
drive out to right polanco got a good
jump on it and he'll make the catch
[Applause]
actually threw that ball kind of where
he where he was sitting now he sends
that a long way but
he is retired he can swing the bat and
he's the final out
got him with a splitter his third k
there goes anderson out on strikes
strikeout number four for godzilla and
this is more like it for the cat man
he remembers it first and second for
brian reynolds
and he walked him and they got the bases
loaded again here with two outs this
time for
moran who walked last hitting
slice to left aj pollock makes the catch
and the pirates leave
them loaded again justin turner who
homered
in the first in his tenth of the year on
two one turner
flies one down the line to left tom
moves over to the corner
he leaps and it's gone turner gets him
again
turner two the pirates won
off tom's glove and into the seats
and on a pair of justin turner's home
runs the dodgers have a lead in the
third
here's the one two and a swing and a
soft ground ball snared
by anderson pardon me line drive low
liner that's caught
broken bat pop up on the infield two
outs
anderson looks for a one two three
inning
fly ball toward left and he'll get it
here is the 35 year old david price now
replacing
victor gonzalez who faced four batters
and retired each
other two retires tom quickly on three
pitches he strikes him out
price delivers and it was the same pitch
but it's bounced toward
short nice easy play for gavin lux as he
tosses it over to pujols at first base
6'3 goes to put up
target set away for this 2-2 pitch
slash down the line to left pollock was
positioned over there and he makes the
catch
career below 78
taps it back to anderson
and carrying that bat with him
[Music]
it's a one hop onto hayes fields it
weighs high and throws a strike on the
first two gone
turner has homework twice turner 5 15
lifetime now against anderson
there's a ground ball to short now they
executed that
bouncing ball back to price he'll go to
second
great stretch from taylor to keep his
foot in the bag
reynolds on with the force play colin
moran now
oh what didn't sound good that did not
sound good
oh boy he's out of the ball game yeah it
must be swelling
quite a bit for gg money take him out
right away
just back on sunday and wouldn't you
know it so second and third two away
here kevin newman is walked and grounded
out
and this ball is lifted into center
field over toward right center is
bellinger
and the pirates strand two more they've
stranded eight
runners through five innings first and
second brings up gavin lux
he's a gamer he's he's trying to talk
about it right now oh he did
[Applause]
how about it tyler anderson
[Applause]
pokes one to right that's a fair ball
over to cut it off polanco
taylor's headed for third turner's got
his third hit of the evening
and the dodgers have him cornered it's
first and third
here comes albert pujols here's the 01.
and that ball tapped up
third hayes comes in has it and on to
first
gets pujols by four or five steps and
the inning comes to an end janssen will
be looking for a four
out save 0-2 got him looking like a
house by the side of the road he watches
a fastball at 95
split the plate and we go to the ninth
running for the first time tonight been
plagued with an ankle concern
did not start he swings and swats one
out to center
reynolds weights on it to come down one
more pitch for howard
vets saw that it was not the fastball
and
made the decision better swing and he
flies out to right
[Applause]
grounded to keep ryan hayes he'll throw
to second
as ken lee jansen looks for save number
14 trying to
close things up tying runners on nobody
are out
and stallings is going to pitch it
[Applause]
slotted to center field bellinger's
there
doubles up on it bouncer to third
turner's only players at first
two gone so two outs the tying run
tom moves to second and it's all up to
key brian hayes
[Music]
game over kenley janssen spears the
comebacker
and the dodgers win it 2-1